a former nfl player becomes the
quintessential tall tough guy a star
trades his badge for border terriers and
one cadet transitions into a lifelong
santa claus the stars of police academy
moved on to other things but which of
them were bigger or better keep watching
to find out
steve gutenberg was already gaining
plenty of traction in his screen acting
career thanks to films like diner and tv
series like billy by the time the role
of carrie mahoney and police academy
came to him gutenberg's lovable
scoundrel performance in the film helped
make it a hit and helped launch him into
some of the biggest films of the 1980s
throughout the rest of the decade he
starred in three police academy sequels
as well as short circuit cocoon and
three men and a baby he continued
working regularly in the 1990s in comedy
and family films like the big green home
for the holidays and it takes two and in
the 2000s he won a role in cult favorite
tv series veronica mars today he
continues acting regularly and in 2017
he started appearing alongside dwayne
johnson in the hbo series ballers in
2002 he moved behind the camera making
his directorial debut with an adaptation
of james kirkwood jr's play ps your cat
is dead
by the time police academy arrived in
theaters kim catrell had already
co-starred in one classic of the 1980s
playing a somewhat infamous role in the
1981 comedy porkies as cadet karen
thompson she got to become a little more
of a fully fledged character which led
to more high profile films throughout
the rest of the decade though she didn't
return for any of the police academy
sequels why
because it's exciting it's different
it'll give me a chance to meet
interesting and unusual people right now
cottrell followed up police academy with
roles in big trouble in little china
mannequin star trek vi the undiscovered
country and more but the role of her
life was yet to come in 1998 she was
cast as samantha jones in the hbo comedy
sex and the city and her performance as
the sex-positive outrageous member of
the show's key foursome made her a fan
favorite she remained with the show
throughout its six season run on hbo and
later returned as samantha for two
feature films since sex and the city
ended she has continued working
regularly including roles in the tv
series producing parker sensitive skin
modus and tell me a story
george gaines screen acting credits
already stretched back nearly 30 years
by the time he was cast as commandant
lassard in police academy and his work
included roles in colombo washington
behind closed doors and tootsie playing
lassard brought gains a new level of
visibility for 1980s moviegoers and it
was the first step toward a new level of
stardom that new stardom also included a
leading role in the sitcom punky
brewster in which he played henry
warnamont and voiced the character again
in an animated spin-off series between
police academy and punky brewster gaines
became an icon of 1980s pop culture he
continued working regularly throughout
the 1990s with roles in the days and
nights of mali dodd hearts of fire and
continued to play lassard in all six
police academy sequels as well as a
brief appearance in the tv series by the
end of the 1990s gaines had largely
retired from screen acting and his last
appearance was a brief role in the 2003
comedy just married he died on february
15 2016 at the age of 98.
michael winslow started appearing in
films in 1980 and co-starred in two
cheech and chong films before police
academy rolled around in 1984. as cadet
larvell jones winslow's incredible
talent for generating seemingly any
sound effect with only his mouth made
him one of the standout stars and
cemented his place in the pop culture of
the 1980s
[Music]
winslow continued to play jones in every
subsequent sequel he also returned to
play larval jones as a police sergeant
in the police academy tv series in 1997.
outside the police academy franchise
winslow has kept busy ever since with
roles in the love boat spaceballs harry
and the hendersons and more
unsurprisingly he's also a gifted voice
actor who has loaned his talents to the
new kids on the block animated series
grand theft auto san andreas robot
chicken and more he's also a stand-up
comedy performer and released a concert
film in 1999. in addition to acting
winslow is also a musician who has
released his own music and collaborated
with acts including run the jewels and
victor wooten
before police academy leslie easterbrook
was best known for playing rhonda lee
the neighbor of the title characters of
the hit sitcom laverne and shirley for
its final three seasons between 1980 and
1983. as sergeant callahan in police
academy she played the tough-as-nails
woman in a man's job who also had a
secret side and while she didn't return
for police academy 2 she did reprise her
role for the remaining 5 sequels and the
tv series after police academy easter
brook continued working regularly
racking up dozens of television
appearances in the 1980s and 1990s
including guest spots on murder she
wrote hanging with mr cooper hunter
matlock and baywatch in 2005 she took
over the role of mother firefly and rob
zombies the devil's rejects and since
then has become something of a scream
queen appearing in horror films
including zombies own halloween remake
the afflicted and sorority party
massacre
gw bailey was already an established
character actor with guest starring
roles on saint elsewhere mash goodnight
beantown and others when he was cast as
the brutal lieutenant harris and police
academy you people are going to hate my
guts for the rest of your lives
i am going to make you sorry that you
ever came here he continued to play
lieutenant harris throughout the police
academy franchise and has worked
regularly ever since among bailly's
numerous screen credits are the film's
short circuit mannequin and a voice role
in the animated home on the range he has
appeared even more frequently on
television including the mini-series war
and remembrance and the series the jeff
foxworthy show murder she wrote american
dreams and the closer in the closer he
played lapd detective lieutenant louis
provenza for 109 episodes then crossed
over into the tnt drama series major
crimes where he played the character
until the series ended in 2018
david graf spent several years working
primarily as a guest actor on episodes
of various tv series before he was cast
in the career-defining role of
tackleberry in police academy
tackleberry a gung-ho security guard who
couldn't wait to join the police force
and seemed to always be armed and ready
to shoot something was a key archetype
in the original film and became one of
the franchise's most recognizable
characters
son
where did you get this gun
my mom gave it to me
raph returned to reprise the role for
all six sequels and co-starred in the
police academy television series in the
late 1990s braf continued working
regularly in film and television
throughout the 1980s and 1990s in 1986
he co-starred in the short-lived sitcom
he's the mayor and in the 1990s and
early 2000s he appeared frequently in tv
series including seinfeld home
improvement step by step and star trek
deep space nine he was also an
accomplished voice actor appearing in
series and video games including ah real
monsters and the wild thornberrys he
died suddenly from a heart attack on
april 7 2001 at the age of 50.
an imposing figure but a lovable guy
moses hightower is probably the most
memorable and beloved character from the
entire police academy franchise it's the
signature role of charles bubba smith an
nfl star in the 1960s and 1970s who
pivoted to playing tall tough guys on
sitcoms and in movies following police
academy smith reprised his role in five
sequel movies and the spin-off tv show
co-starred on short-lived shows
including blue thunder and half nelson
and turned in appearances in taxi heart
to heart married with children and coach
in august 2011 66 year old smith was
found dead at his los angeles home
according to the los angeles times the
la county coroner's office conducted an
autopsy that concluded the actor died of
an overdose of weight loss medication
and also suffered from blocked arteries
high blood pressure and an enlarged
heart
police academy is notable for having not
only an ensemble of likable hero
characters but a similar ensemble of
unlikable villainous characters
including scott thompson's cadet chad
copeland thompson who before police
academy also appeared in another 80s
classic fast times at ridgemont high
hasn't appeared in as many police
academy installments as some of his
co-stars but he still reprised the role
in the third and fourth movies thompson
has continued working in film and
television since the franchise his tv
roles include star trek the next
generation hunter parker lewis can't
lose and true blood while his film roles
include my summer story knight of the
living dead 3d reanimation and greater
he also matched police academy with an
appearance in one of the most popular
films of the 1990s playing the classical
music blaring stormchaser preacher in
twister
after a couple of sitcom and soap opera
gigs in the late 1970s mary and ramsay
finally found a breakout role as the
squeaky voiced and deceptively powerful
cadet laverne hooks
she made her debut as hooks in 1984's
police academy and went on to reprise
the role in five sequels becoming a firm
fan favorite she didn't appear in the
final police academy movie 1994's
mission to moscow because producers
couldn't find a place for her character
this came as bad news for ramsay who was
going through financial troubles at the
time she would ultimately take out a
loan from police academy co-star bubba
smith who dropped out of the film over
ramsay's omission ramsay would ride out
the 90s and early 2000s with small parts
and voice acting work popping up on
beverly hills 90210 robot chicken and
the animated tv version of the addams
family her last role came in the musical
docudrama when i sing in 2018 preceding
her death in 2021 she was 73. captain
reed the one-time boss of cadet
mahoney's father sets the plot of police
academy in motion offering mahoney a
choice of punishment for his crimes he
can go to prison or he can go legit by
joining the academy actor ted ross best
known for his tony award-winning work as
the lion in the broadway musical the wiz
and its 1978 film adaptation played
captain reed in the first police academy
but he didn't return for any of the
sequels he wrapped up a long career in
show business not long after the film's
1984 release with appearances in arthur
2 on the rocks the cosby show and the
fisher king he retired from acting in
1991 and moved back to his hometown of
dayton ohio in 1997 he opened a jazz
club called your place where he'd
perform on occasion after suffering a
stroke in 1998 that left him homebound
ross died at age 68 in 2002
donovan scott's screen acting career
began with a number of smaller roles in
films before he was cast as leslie
barbera in police academy like catrol
scott was one of the original cast
members who did not return for other
installments in the franchise since
police academy scott has worked
regularly in film and television his
film roles include savannah smiles
splash 2 and blast from the past while
his tv roles include life with lucy
alaska kid babylon 5 boston legal my
name is earl and many others in recent
years scott has taken a liking to
playing santa claus and frequently
appears as santa in various films and
television series his many santa
appearances include episodes of frasier
it's always sunny in philadelphia the
middle life and pieces and superstore as
well as tv movies like north pole open
for christmas and santa switch
the character mr wig played by don lake
makes a brief but important appearance
in the first police academy movie it's
his card that carrie mahoney wrecks
while working as a parking lot attendant
after police academy lake established
himself as a recognizable character
actor becoming a familiar face with
appearances in a number of major
comedies lake was a member of the trope
associated with the mockumentaries of
christopher guest and co-starred in a
mighty wind waiting for guffman best in
show for your consideration and mascot
while also popping up in terminator 2
and return to me which he co-wrote with
frequent collaborator bonnie hunt lake
wrote for hunt's talk show and sitcom
life with bonnie and they played the
parents of officer judy hopps and
disney's zootopia more recently lake
appeared on space force as incompetent
general brad gregory
cadet doug fackler is responsible for
some of the wackiest antics in the first
police academy movie he's played to
perfection by bruce muller
does the radio bother you
[Music]
i could turn it down
after his screen comedy career was
launched in earnest as a member of the
cast of abc's late night sketch show
fridays mahler played sergeant doug
fackler in four police academy movies he
went on to play some small parts on tv
and in movies before finding his second
recognizable role rabbi glickman a
friend and counselor to elaine venice on
seinfeld with his other notable role
coming in friday the 13th the final
chapter he hasn't been in a feature film
since 2000 preferring instead to spend
time with his family and raise border
terrier dogs
portraying cadet kyle blanks and police
academy was the first feature film work
for actor brant von hoffman and he
returned to the franchise for 1986's
police academy 3 back in training keep
dabble in film and television over the
next two decades showing up in the films
rustlers rhapsody blast from the past
and dudley do right and on the tv series
home improvement barless and arrested
development he hasn't acted on screen
since 2004 having moved into a career as
a writer with his brother todd von
hoffman the former actor wrote two
humorous pop culture compendiums big
damn book of sheer manliness and bigger
damer book of sheer manliness
chief of police in the unidentified city
of police academy and then later police
commissioner henry hurst is the
institutional antagonist of the
franchise at least initially he's
adamantly against his mayor's idea to
open up the police academy to a wider
variety of candidates he hatches the
plan to make them all quit but after it
doesn't work comes to appreciate the new
cadets the acting career of george r
robertson is notable for two things
portraying henry hurst in six police
academy movies between 1984 and 1989 and
for playing politicians both fictional
and real robertson was president davis
in senior trip senator barry goldwater
in the reagans and vice president dick
cheney in the path to 9 11. robertson
stopped taking on as many roles when he
reached his 80s with one of his last
roles coming in the series haven
cadet george martin's main arc as an
officer isn't one of finding a job or
personal purpose but one of romance he's
ditching his relentless pursuit of as
many young women as possible in order to
get together with trainer debbie
callahan andrew rubin was a seasoned
character actor by the time he played
cadet george martin in the first police
academy a career peak that followed
stints on 70s tv shows like mary hartman
mary hartman swat the odd couple shazam
and the jeffersons after police academy
reuben landed main cast parts on the
short-lived drama series hometown and
joe bash then walked away from acting
for about a decade to head up multiple
non-profit and humanitarian
organizations in 2015 ruben died of lung
cancer at the age of 69 according to the
hollywood reporter the main bad guy of
the original police academy movie is
never given a name instead he's a common
intimidating leather jacket and beanie
clad street thug caricature officially
listed in the credits as main bad guy
the part of main bad guy was played by
prolific character actor and bit player
doug lennox who returned to the series
in police academy 3 back in training to
portray axe murder he notched a few
dozen credits in his time most notably
popping up in x-men lars and the real
girl and against the ropes he appeared
in numerous television shows produced in
his native canada including my secret
identity night heat top cops and due
south also a radio host and an author
lennox died in 2015 at age 77.
violet factler knows that her husband
doug has a tendency to slip up and
create mayhem in one memorable scene
from the first police academy she jumps
on the hood of her husband's car to
prevent him from driving to the academy
sign ups only to get hurt in the process
police academy is an iconic 80s movie
and debra lee scott was an iconic
television personality in her day she
made frequent appearances on the
celebrity powered game shows of the era
including family feud match game and
password plus as a young actor she
appeared on the love boat had a
recurring role on welcome back cotter
and she also played the title
character's sister kathy shumway on the
soap spoof mary hartman mary hartman
scott's career came to an end not long
after she reprised the role of violet
fackler in 1986's police academy 3 back
in training she focused on her personal
life and became engaged to new york city
police officer dennis levi who died at
the world trade center during the 9 11
terrorist attacks according to contact
music scott's family reported that the
tragedy sent the retired actor into a
depression that led her to drink heavily
which resulted in cirrhosis of the liver
scott died in april 2005 at age 52.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite classic comedy actors are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]